[Musique]
chers amis bienvenue pour cette belle
après-midi qui nous réunit ici au
port-marly aux côtés de notre président
christian jacob
nous allons dans quelques instants vous
pouvez l'applaudir
nous allons dans quelques instants
débuter une nouvelle table ronde autour
de la république et des réussites mais
avant cela je voudrais vous dire
quelques mots
parce que c'est une la dernière fois que
je m'exprimerai devant vous est ce que
je veux d'abord vous dire c'est merci
merci de nous avoir permis de relever ce
défi merci d'être plus de mille
aujourd'hui à port marly
merci d'avoir fait mentir toutes celles
et ceux qui pensaient que la droite ne
pouvait plus parler à la jeunesse qui
pensaient que nous étions incapables de
réunir 1000 jeunes pour débattre des
idées et du fonds depuis deux jours vous
avez fait mentir tous les pronostics
merci d'être là merci d'être fidèle
merci de ne pas être des feuilles au
vent merci de ne pas être partis y
compris lorsque la période était
difficile
la plus grande des indignités c'est de
se perdre
c'est aux maires qui le dit en parlant à
ulysse ou en faisant parler ulysse vous
ne vous êtes pas perdu vous êtes ici au
bon endroit et vous savez pourquoi vous
n'avez pas quitté les républicains parce
que vous croyez en ces grandes valeurs
qui ont toujours fait l'histoire de la
droite française vous croyez en notre
avenir
merci donc à vous de ne pas nous avoir
quittés et d'être là pour reconstruire
la maison
enfin
je voudrais que nous puissions remercier
notre président christian jacob celles
et ceux qui me connaissent savent que je
ne suis pas très doué dans les
flatteries gratuite en revanche
lorsqu'un homme est capable de consacrer
autant d'énergie autant de force autant
de détermination à autre chose que son
seul parcours politique lorsqu'un homme
est capable de consacrer toute son
énergie à servir et à servir une cause à
servir une famille politique il faut le
remercier il faut le saluer dans cette
période
dans cette période il semble que
quelques uns se soit perdu nous ne
sommes pas perdu nous savons qui nous
sommes nous sommes les républicains nous
sommes les héritiers du général de
gaulle de cette grande et formidable
idée que la france ne se souvenait
jamais nous sommes les héritiers d'une
idée moderne généreuse progressiste peut
être celle de georges pompidou
nous sommes les héritiers de cette idée
que la culture française ne s'étant pas
ne s'éteint pas qu'elle est capable de
s'ancrer dans la modernité
nous sommes les sommes les héritiers de
jacques chirac de cette idée
profondément humaniste de notre société
de cette idée que la droite n'est jamais
borgne qu'elle est capable de regarder
la france avec autorité mais aussi avec
générosité et avec justice nous sommes
les héritiers des grands combats sur le
handicap des grands combats pour la
protection des femmes
nous sommes les héritiers de simone veil
nous sommes cette grande et belle
histoire sommes les héritiers les
héritiers les successeurs de nicolas
sarkozy de cet immense idée que la
volonté politique peut transformer la
société que les idées peuvent changer le
cours des choses que les idées
politiques mérite mieux que tout autre
chose pour transformer le monde
nous sommes ses héritiers là et nous
sommes les républicains depuis deux
jours vous avez été le visage et
républicains il nous faut maintenant
faire en sorte que cette parole là nous
puissions la porter à l'égard de la
france tout entière
la grande ambition la droite
républicaine n'a jamais été de se parler
seulement tél
la grande et belle ambition la droite
républicaine a toujours été de parler à
la france de parler à tous les français
d'en porter avec nous toute la nation
voilà le défi que nous ne réussirons pas
sans la jeunesse c'est avec vous que
nous réussirons à faire en sorte que
demain la droite républicaine soit celle
qui rassemble l'ensemble des françaises
et des français
cette table ronde je sais qu'elle est
attendu et je veux dire pour conclure à
tous les observateurs que vous avez bien
fait de venir parce que cet après midi
on se dire des choses extrêmement
importantes
vous avez raison cet après midi il vous
faut observer chaque virgule
chaque mot chaque intention chaque
intonation lorsque cet après midi vous
aurez de grandes déclarations
vous aurez de grandes déclarations vous
aurez de grandes déclarations sur ceux
qui comptent plus que tous nos idées nos
convictions nos valeurs républicaines
vous avez raison d'être attentif parce
que cet après midi nous allons parler de
ce qui peut intéresser vraiment les
français la république et les réussites
au sein de la république
voilà ce qui compte voilà la thérapie à
laquelle nous nous sommes soumises
depuis deux jours parler des idées
parler des convictions parler de ce que
nous voulons pour les français et pas
seulement ce que nous voulons pour nous
mêmes j'espère et je suis convaincu que
cet après midi vous permettra de finir
votre guérison et de vous dire que ce
qui compte plus que tout en politique ce
sont les idées les idées encore et
toujours les idées les chers amis merci
encore d'être là je passe à paroles
sommes aussitôt à christian jacob avant
de la passer à valentin qui va nous dire
quelques mots sur les ateliers d'hyères
ces six ans tu as la parole merci merci
aurélien merci à vous tous j'aurais
l'occasion de redire dans quelques
instants
c'est bon mais c'est la vie politique
c'est aussi l'histoire du compagnonnage
une nouvelle triste qui nous touche qui
touche 1 va toucher beaucoup d'entre
vous tous ceux qui ont été cette jeune
garde chiraquienne de 95 à nos amis à
nos grands compagnon antoine ruffenach
qui est décédé voilà je voulais avoir ne
pas démarrer cette après midi sans avoir
une pensée pour lui
je le dis aux amis de seine-maritime qui
sont là mais à vous tous et vous tout
vous êtes nombreux à ne pas l'avoir
connu mais sur les premiers rangs nous
sommes nombreux à l'avoir connu avoir
été à ses côtés et savoir quel grand
maire du havre ça a été quel grand homme
est vraiment tu parlais de gaulliste
d'hommes de conviction sans été un sacré
hommage à antoine
merci de questions il reprendra la
parole aussitôt après on va passer la
parole à valentin vous le savez ces deux
journées elles ont été placées sous les
couleurs de la jeunesse sont les jeunes
qui ont fait les débats et qui ont
participé aux ateliers et valentin et le
rapporteur de l'atelier qui s'est tenue
hier sur la conciliation de cette belle
idée de la république et des réussites
il va donc nous dire ce qui s'est dit
hier et ce à quoi il nous faut être
attentif merci beaucoup monsieur prady
merci beaucoup monsieur jacob de me
donner la parole à cet après midi je
peux vous je peux vous appeler christian
parfait alors déjà le premier le premier
constat que je peux faire sur cet
atelier c'est que au delà des
propositions des solutions qui ont été
qui ont été données et beaucoup de
témoignages et je pense que c'est pour
ça que c'était important que les jeunes
puissent avoir la parole ce week end
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de témoignages
et du vécu et c'est peut-être parce et
remonter là que le projet peut être
construit pour les prochaines séances
ensuite la première chose qu'on a qu'on
a faites au début de l'atelier c'est un
constat le premier constat c'est que la
france est et énormément fracturé la
fracture sociale
la fracture territoriale la fracture
numérique aussi qui empêche un certain
nombre de réussites de ce faire il ya eu
beaucoup de propositions sur l'éducation
et beaucoup de plaintes de doléances
notamment sur sur les questions
d'orientation des filières générales
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop plein il ya
aussi peut-être des réformes au lycée
entreprendre notamment
voilà la valorisation des filières
professionnelles des filières
technologiques
on avait avec nous ronan le gleut et
daniel fasquelle qui nous ont beaucoup
parler justement de la notion
d'apprentissage de l'intelligence de la
main et ronan le gleut qui est sénateur
à l'étranger sénateur des français de
l'étranger en allemagne qui nous a
beaucoup parlé et qui nous a dit que la
différence entre la culture allemande et
la culture française c'est que dans la
culture allemande vient justement
beaucoup plus de valorisation de
l'intelligence de la main et s'est aussi
essayée c'est ce qu'il a expliqué c'est
aussi pour ça que peut-être le chômage
des jeunes en allemagne est beaucoup
plus bas que le nôtre voilà ensuite on a
beaucoup parlé du service militaire
qui était une vraie question beaucoup
regrettent qu'on ait supprimé le service
militaire à l'époque parce qu'il avait
beaucoup de valeurs des valeurs
d'intégration les valeurs de mixité
sociale et on a eu le témoignage d'un
jeune qui a fait le service à sa
universel tel qu'il a été proposé par
emmanuel macron et
il a eu deux remontées de constat c'est
que déjà c'était une colonie de vacances
et le deuxième constat c'est que quinze
jours c'était beaucoup trop court donc
je pense qu'il ya peut-être une réforme
sur le service national pas forcément
militaire mais il ya peut-être une une
étude à faire sur la durée d'un service
militaire avec beaucoup plus de mixité
et d'intégration
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
se sont éloignés de la république qui
sont en perte de repères et je pense que
l'idée d'un service national peut être
une bonne proposition pour les ramener
vers vers la république ensuite ç'a eu
beaucoup de questions sur la ruralité
sur la fracture territoriale et je suis
content que françois barbance voilà ça
tape les midis en tant que président de
l'aef
parce que voilà on a fait le constat qui
avait beaucoup de territoires beaucoup
trop enclavé notamment sur la question
du numérique on à emmanuel macron qui
nous a proposé un quine qui nous avait
promis en 2007 lors de l'élection
présidentielle qu'il mettrait le haut
débit dans toute la france sur ce sujet
comme beaucoup d'autres il a failli donc
on a on a on a vraiment besoin que les
zones blanches s'arrête on a besoin que
les territoires sa désenclaver notamment
sur la question médicale on avait un
étudiant en médecine qui nous expliquait
qu' il était il était étudiant et que
quand il a dû être y ait une licence ils
avaient une licence de médecine fait une
faculté de médecine juste à côté de chez
lui
on a préféré l'envoyer dans une dent
universités beaucoup plus loin nos
pareil il ya des territoires qui sont
pas assez valorisés sur le territoire
ensuite on a parlé beaucoup
d'universités et du lien entre
l'université et les entreprises
il n'y a pas assez de liens je pense que
les licences sont pas assez
professionnalisante et à la fin on a
beaucoup parlé aussi de
l'entrepreneuriat et c'est là où ça m'a
beaucoup beaucoup marqué parce que il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui veulent
entreprendre et
et même s'il ya beaucoup de dispositifs
qui sont faits en termes de l'allègement
des charges sociales pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs
il ya un manque d'accompagnement pour
les jeunes entrepreneurs
et pour conclure moi ce qui m'a
énormément marqué et c'est je pense un
peu le fil rouge de cet atelier c'est
qu'à aucun moment aucun jeune n'a
réclamé l'assistanat et je pense que la
droite c'est ça la jeunesse de droite
quand on veut réconcilier république et
réussit c'est pas mettre en place les
conditions de l'assistanat c'est mettre
en place une vraie méritocratie un vrai
un ascenseur social s'en sortir par le
travail
aucun demander des dons n'a pas parlé du
rsa on n'a pas parlé d' aide les jeunes
ils n'ont pas besoin d'assistanat il
veut juste qu'on leur donne les clés
pour réussir il veut qu'on nous donne
les clés pour réussir il veut pas qu'on
fasse à leur place et je pense que c'est
ce projet
c'est cette idée c'est l'idée de la
méritocratie républicaine que la
jeunesse de droite devra porter pour les
prochaines échéances électorales
et merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté et
et voilà merci beaucoup
où l applaudir largement merci beaucoup
valentin et à travers toi tous les tous
les jeunes qui ont fait un travail
absolument remarquable depuis deux jours
mais sa parole à christian jacob pour
accueillir notre intervenant mystère
bien écoutez je vais effectivement
invité à monter sur l'estrade quelqu'un
qui a un petit peu de pression sur les
épaules depuis quelques jours mais vous
savez je suis sans doute un de ceux
qu'il connaît le mieux dans cette salle
est depuis plus longtemps
il a le sang froid la compétence
expérience et puis un caractère bien
trempé pour résister à tout cela donc le
sujet qui nous réunit après midi est
pourquoi nous avons demandé à françois
de témoigner cet après midi c'est pour
la raison suivante d'abord c'est le
maire de troyes depuis 82 puis 95 maire
de troyes c'est à dire une cité urbaine
ouvrière dans un grand département dans
un grand département rural qui a subi
les chocs de désindustrialisation où il
ya eu des périodes de chômage de tension
très forte
il a su redonner cette dynamique à sa
ville il est aussi le le prédit le
président apprécié à contester
soutenu par je crois tous les maires de
france président de de la mf il exerce
est cette mission avec avec brio il a
été aussi le ministre de l'économie et
des finances dans une période très
difficile de notre pays aux côtés de
nicolas sarkozy et c'est pour ces
raisons que nous avons demandé à
françois de témoigner il a été aussi il
a fait un travail je le dis avec gérard
larcher avec l'association des régions
de france renaud muselier avec nous
voilà il est lent avec l'association des
départements de france dans territoire
unis pour réfléchir sur la
décentralisation la déconcentration des
services de l'état comment l'état peut
être plus efficace accompagner au mieux
nos compatriotes m'accompagner aussi les
entreprises l'accès aux services publics
tous ces sujets que valentin vient de
bien d'expliquer voilà toutes les bonnes
raisons pour lesquelles on a invité
françois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
viens de le dire je suis président de la
m
comment ça démarre tout de suite face à
toi et les jeunes prendront la parole
après bonjour à toutes et à tous d'abord
je voudrais ainsi vous me le permettez
avoir comme christian jacob une pensée
pour antoine ruffenach il ya ici gérard
larcher rachida dati renaud muselier
eric ciotti valérie bazin malgré un
député annie genevard bruno retailleau
toutes nos amis virginie du billère
daniel fasquelle là l'ami européen fort
proust et puis agnès evren qui est
l'incarnation de la relève de notre
famille politique lui rends hommage
parce que voilà une jeune femme qui il y
à quelques quelques années ma ma
compagne est effectivement dans
l'exercice ministériel que nicolas
sarkozy m'avait confié au coeur de cette
crise et qui a été une collaboratrice
merveilleuse et à qui j'ai dit mais elle
ne le croyais pas tu as les qualités
pour entrer en politique tu as les
qualités pour t'engager tu voues
beaucoup plus que ce que tu penses et eu
un potentiel qui est plus important ce
que ce que tu imagines crois en toi sens
que tu as en toi regarde si tu peux
avoir cette détermination je pense que
tu as le caractère je pense que tu as le
tempérament je pense que tu as l'énergie
je pense que tu as et les valeurs et je
t'aiderai et année c'est vrai elle est
pour moi l'incarnation de quelque sorte
ce que vous faites aujourd'hui ici à
port marly de tout ce que l'on fait au
jour
jour après jour pour faire valoir nos
convictions nos valeurs elle est droite
ne dévie pas elle n'hésite pas entre la
démission la tradition la désertion
l'oubli l'abandon elle a ses valeurs
elle croit aux républicains elle a pris
la fédé de paris elle croit à paris elle
a accompagné rachida dati
elles ont mené contre toute attente
alors que l'immense majorité des gens
attendraient près les européennes qui
n'est pas de candidat de notre famille à
paris pour mener un combat une nouvelle
génération s'élever à paris comme
partout en france une nouvelle
génération demande un espoir à paris
comme partout en france et une nouvelle
génération grâce à vous se lève
à port marly vous êtes l'avenir des
républicains et vous êtes l'avenir de la
france et cet hommage à antoine
ruffenach il est cette exigence qui est
la nôtre de transmission de ces valeurs
antoine ruffenach c'est quelqu'un qui a
grandi en politique sous l'autorité du
général de gaulle et qui ensuite a fait
son parcours public et privé dans les
années 70 il a toujours accompagné
jacques chirac est à l' annonce de son
décès juste avant de rentrer dans cette
salle pour vous rejoindre
on s'est regardés avec christian et avec
quelques autres et on n'a pas oublié
cette intelligence cette malice cette
dignité
cette élégance du regard d'antoine
roussennac lorsqu'il était directeur de
campagne de jacques chirac en 2002 et
qui pour rassembler toute la famille
dans un premier temps et ensuite
affronter le pen dans un second
mouvement avec la distance nécessaire le
recul nécessaire et c'était un
chiraquien
donc il aimait la pression ça faut le
savoir tous les chiraquiens aime la
pression donc ya pas de problème un peu
plus un peu moins c'est de toute façon
toujours sa bulle et et antoine rusnak
c'était ça et c'est un maire du havre
extraordinaire il a mené un combat
politique
comme beaucoup d'entre vous ont mené ce
combat politique au cours des dernières
municipales la ville du havre
c'est une ville historiquement
communiste il a sorti les communistes de
leur folie de projets marxiste du havre
il a reconstruit il a redéfini des
politiques publiques de proximité
il a fait corps avec le havre c'est
l'histoire du havre c'est le renouveau
du havre et c'est aussi l'histoire de
notre famille et c'est normal que nous
ayons les pensées les plus chaleureuses
affectueuse pour lui c'est une part de
nous mêmes qui s'en va mais c'est aussi
une part de nous-mêmes qui est transmis
à vous la relève des républicains
on tourne une page du même livre et sans
transition je voudrais je voudrais dire
que cette relève vous l'avez à vous
coûter 20 jeunes rdj qui a d'abord un
point de vue un peu plus élevé que les
autres s'ils étaient en dessous au
premier enjeu il voit très loin les très
grands j'étais à sa table à côté c'est
assez merveilleux d'échanger et partager
c'est assez agréable de pouvoir discuter
justement imaginer voir quels sont les
ressorts de cette nouvelle génération de
responsables politiques tout ça
formidable et celles à venir
mais vous avez aussi à la tête du parti
les gens de grande valeur et d'une
génération qui doit être réconfortante
et rassurante pour vous aurez bien
prades et notre secrétaire général fait
un travail formidable
c'est un garçon intelligent est un
garçon courageux et il faut bien voir
quels voir gagner comme valérie bazin
malgras d'ailleurs une élection
législative dans la vague macron où plus
personne ne nous regardait dans un
département radical socialiste où
l'histoire justement de l'organisation
des majorités d'idées qu'ils faisaient
et défaisaient toute une série de
parlementaires nécessitait quand même
d'avoir beaucoup de tempérament et quand
j'ai vu qu aurélien pradié élus dans ce
département dans cette vague extrêmement
difficile trois semaines après la
présidentielle
j'y suis là il a des qualités et la plus
que des qualités il a une vision il a du
caractère il a du tempérament et il a
surtout des convictions chevillée à
l'âme et une sensibilité une humanité
une volonté aussi de porter la dimension
sociale de notre famille politique qui
fait que incontestablement nous avons
aussi dans la génération qui est juste
devant et juste derrière la nôtre une
relève qui est formidable
d'abord dans la compréhension
l'organisation notre pays ensuite dans
la dynamique que le parlement peut
apporter dans son rôle d'opposition
démocratique et enfin dans la
reconstruction de notre formation
politique vous avez beaucoup de chance
et nous avons beaucoup de chance d'avoir
comme
traiteur général au rallye un brasier et
je voulais le lui dire ici pour la
première fois et le remercier de tout
son travail aux côtés de l'équipe
dirigeante et aux côtés évidemment de
tous les acteurs et enfin christian
jacob
christian jacob est évidemment les
frères de l'est en chiraquie et j'ai
accepté de revenir dans les instances
dirigeantes il ya un peu plus d'un an
parce que sécréter christian jacob qui
venait d'être élu par les militants
question est probablement l'incarnation
de ce que le gaullisme le chiraquisme la
fidélité aux valeurs qui ont été
développés par aurélien pas de pradier
se fait de mieux dans la constance dans
la droiture dans le courage dans
l'abnégation dans l'intelligence la
première intelligence et que lorsqu'il a
été nommé pour la première fois au
gouvernement par jacques chirac
jackass est sa responsabilité des
exploitants agricoles de chefs
d'entreprise qui a développé toute une
série d'activités dans le domaine
agricole et on l'attendait sur
l'aviculture est nommé ministre de la
famille alors ça c'était les trucs de
chirac il aimait bien jouer au bonneteau
et y'avait muselier qui continue d'en
rire encore un peu aujourd'hui sous son
masque et
et qu'est ce que tu vas faire attention
chirac m'a demandé d'être ministre de la
famille jette ministère famille c'était
un grand ministre de la famille
ensuite il pas fonctionnaire était
ministre de la fonction publique
le seul ministre de la fonction publique
qui a réussi sans grève au bout de la
nuit à obtenir des accords qui ont
permis des avancées significatives de
garantie et de protection du rôle et de
la place de nos agents de l'état de nos
agents territoriaux de nos agents
hospitaliers
il a été un grand ministre c'est un
grand député le voisin que je suis peut
dire que c'est un grand maire de provins
et il a été dans toutes les périodes
notamment les plus difficiles de
l'histoire récente le seul à pouvoir
tenir le groupe parlementaire qui était
nourri animé de forces centrifuges
dilatant un petit peu le modèle
il a permis à toute la famille de rester
nous devons à christian la permanence de
la durée
nous devons à question de s'être engagés
lors des dernières élections
législatives avec courage il n'y en
avait pas tant que cela et pourtant nous
avions une génération de candidats
formidables et il est aller au mastic et
une fois encore il a reprise le répondu
présent pour être le président de notre
parti
c'est un homme de rassemblement c'est un
homme de courage d'un homme de
détermination c'est un homme de valeur
et c'est un homme de service et au
service de la nouvelle génération vous
êtes je veux qu'on lui rende l'hommage
qu'il mérite c'est-à-dire les
applaudissements chaleureux nôi
affectueux reconnaissant et qui permet
de dire que oui
christian nous te devons un immense
merci
un immense merci d'avoir relevé le gant
après des européennes
un immense merci d'avoir organisé des
équipes pour préparer les municipales
un immense merci d'avoir conduit notre
famille politique avec nos alliés à la
victoire aux municipales et à ceux qui
s'interrogent encore aujourd'hui sur le
point de savoir qui a gagné les
municipales
mon cher gérard larcher nous le verrons
aux sénatoriales dans trois semaines le
sénat sous l'autorité de gérard larcher
restera à droite jouera son rôle
républicain organisera la confrontation
avec l'état et la vraie réponse pour
comprendre qui a gagné les municipales
c'est aussi là dans trois semaines nous
nous savons que plus de 50% des villes
se sont retrouvés dans nos valeurs nous
savons que
la gauche s'est reconstitué et qui était
un sujet d'interrogation pour nous
autour des insoumis autour de certains
écolos totalitaire qui ait une vision
qui veulent imposer aux autres leur mode
de vie et autour de ce qui reste du
parti socialiste mais nous savons aussi
que le parti du président a connu une
déroute comme jamais aucun parti depuis
cinquante-huit a connu une déroute dans
une élection locale 3 4% moins de 2000
élus des score humiliant
sur les 550 mille élus et on continue
d'expliquer que le cadre général du
socle permet aujourd'hui à ce pouvoir
d'imaginer espérer un rebond
rien dans les territoires une
incompréhension complète et tous les
représentants de marche ou de leurs
alliés qui se sont présentés aux
municipales ont porté le même message
distant ne donnant pas le sentiment de
comprendre la réalité du coin de la rue
imaginant encore un peu plus une
organisation lointaine administrative du
rock a trick est administré de manière
ultra centralisée des scores à 5%
ici à 3 6% à reims ailleurs partout y a
personne
aucun élu dans marche du président ne se
trouve aujourd'hui dans ce territoire
c'est nous qui portons le pays du code
la rue c'est nous qui portons l'avenir
du pays sur le pays réel et son avenir
c'est nous qui avons le devoir d'être
aux côtés des français pour apaiser
leurs peurs organisé justement le cadre
général de traverser cette période avec
le co vide permettre le rebond
territorial et économique
actionner le plan de relance avec les
régions avec les départements avec les
communes avec les intercommunalités
l'avenir du pays passe d'abord et avant
tout par le poids de la rue et donc
tout par celles et ceux qui conduisent
aux destinées de chacune de nos
miscibilité nous sommes majoritaires de
ce point de vue dans le prix
il faut le dire le répéter tout le monde
n'en émettent peut-être même pas
conscients dans la salle
soyez en conscients soyez confiants
c'est ça l'élément de reconstruction et
ça va s'appuyer dans les semaines et
dans les mois qui viennent justement sur
la dynamique qui est créé dans nos
villes soyons fiers de ce que nous avons
fait aux municipales sous l'autorité
l'animation de christian jacob en
coordination avec nos alliés et avec une
génération d'élus locaux extraordinaire
qu'ils relèvent le gant et qui va
diriger les villes de france
alors oui que c'était un échange et il
faut que je parle quand même de
république et de réussite très
brièvement dans la logique de
réconciliation
un mot sur la république parce que pour
bien comprendre la pomme promesse
républicaine qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes dans un mouvement politique le
nôtre vous êtes par votre construction
personnelle par vos valeurs parce que
vous ont transmis vos parents pas votre
regard pour votre acte citoyen de cet
engagement
attaché à ce modèle républicain mais a
toujours beaucoup de confusion autour de
ce que l'on attend de cette promesse
républicaine la république elle repose
effectivement sur des idées simples qui
sont des valeurs
ce qu'on oublie de dire c'est que ce
soit des valeurs mais sont aussi des
règles et à partir de ce moment là on a
déjà une clarification de ce que veut
dire la république quand on parle de
liberté la liberté est la règle
il n'y a pas de liberté sans règles
c'est ça qui construit l'état de droit
et quand les règles ne sont pas
respectées par l'état de droit c'est
l'effondrement de l'autorité
je prends un exemple récent notre dame
des landes tout l'état de droit a
construit une autorité pour que ce
projet soutenu par les élus locaux
soutenus par l'état soutenu par tous les
acteurs
arrivés à la conclusion qu'il fallait
que ça se fasse et à la fin celui qui
incarne l'autorité
le gouvernement a dit ça ne se fera pas
parce que le droit de la force
l'occupation illicite les analystes
s'est engagé dans un bras de fer qu'il a
gagné face à la force du droit
et quand c'est l'effacement la force du
droit et que c'est la place au droit de
la force
et bien c'est le début d'un processus
qui altèrent l'autorité nous y sommes et
quant à l'encan on répète matin midi et
soir l'autorité l'autorité l'autorité
vous connaissez cette formule de malraux
l'autorité qui ne conduit pas à l'ordre
mènent au ridicule
parfois j'ai le sentiment depuis la
sortie de l'été
on n'en est pas loin
quand on parle de république on parle de
valeurs on parle de règles il ya une
deuxième valeur c'est l'égalité et si
vous êtes ici aux républicains héritier
de l'ump descendant direct du
rassemblement pour la république c'est
que cette notion d'égalité
elle est étroitement associée dans votre
construction à celle de la liberté on
est très attaché à droite à la liberté
mais je les dis c'est pas la liberté du
renard dans le poulailler c'est pas la
loi du plus fort c'est la liberté avec
des règles la promesse républicaine sur
l'égalité c'est une égalité en droit
c'est pas l'égalité pour tous en même
temps c'est pas l'égalité réelle comme
les socialistes l'ont fait par exemple
avec valjas najat vallaud belkacem à
l'éducation nationale ou dans les autres
territoires l'égalité réelle
ça pousse à la fin un projet de nature
marxiste et le marxisme il a échoué et
nous le savons depuis la fin du mur de
berlin
et cette égalité en droits c'est notre
devoir de construire justement ce projet
de transmission s'éloigner de la
promesse républicaine de l'égalité en
droit c'est rentré sur le terrain
politique qui en suit tire tout le monde
vers le bas c'est l'égalitarisme
c'est le socialisme et le communisme
c'est aujourd'hui une forme de vision
qui amène certains notamment à la
convention citoyenne sur le
développement durable a considéré que
l'urgence du climat n'est pas compatible
avec le modèle démocratique dire des
gens qui veulent s'approprier le pouvoir
pour fixer une vision un repère une
doctrine et finalement la poser à tous
et c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à un
match paris province on ne vit pas de la
même manière partout on n'a pas les
mêmes contraintes
on n'a pas les mêmes traditions on n'a
pas les mêmes aspirations mais pourtant
on veut vous imposer de vivre de la même
part manière partout donc l'égalité
c'est une égalité en droits le reste
c'est le terrain politique et qui doit
nous amener à nous battre
justement pour cette logique d'égalité
en trois quand on parle de république on
parle d'une troisième valeur qui est la
fraternité dans la fraternité parce que
c'est pas si tous les gars du monde
pouvait se donner la main et faire le
tour de la terre la fraternité dans une
action politique
ce sont des politiques de solidarité et
les gaullistes que nous sommes nous
sommes au premier rang de la grande
fierté d'avoir pu porter comme aurélien
pradié avec
certain nombre d'autres le porte
aujourd'hui notamment sur le handicap
mais ce sont toutes les politiques de
solidarité à l'égard des aînés à l'égard
des handicapés à l'égard de celles et
ceux qui ont perdu leur emploi à l'égard
de celles et ceux qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement pendant un temps la
fraternité dans un modèle social comme
le nôtre depuis 45 c'est la sécurité
sociale c'est les minima sociaux
c'est la possibilité d'avoir un état
pour providence qui garantit le fait de
pas être sur le bord du chemin
c'est l'accompagnement des associations
financées par les collectivités locales
pour trouver un toit pour les femmes
battues
c'est le financement des centres
d'hébergement ce sont les aides
d'urgence quand l'hiver arrive
c'est la possibilité d'avoir accompagné
les restos du coeur ou d'autres
associations c'est ça la fraternité
c'est donc un devoir et là dessus les
gaullistes et la droite aussi bien sous
l'autorité du général de gaulle que de
georges pompidou que sous l'autorité et
la responsabilité de jacques chirac et
nicolas sarkozy ont été aux avant-postes
des avancées sociales les plus
importantes du modèle de l'état
providence donc sur ce terrain là nous
n'avons pas non plus à nous excuser de
ce que nous avons fait et c'est même un
devoir d'être à la hauteur de ce que nos
prédécesseurs ont écrit pour nous
permettre aujourd'hui d'être fiers de
cet état providence de cette étape
solidaires de cet état fraternelle enfin
la république même si ça n'est pas au
frontispice de tous les hôtels de ville
de notre pays repose sur la laïcité
c'est un modèle que les objets
anglo-saxon du mal à comprendre puisque
nous n'avons pas la même construction et
n'aurait pas le même regard n'aurait pas
le même rapport
la laïcité c'est une valeur et c'est une
règle c'est une valeur depuis la
séparation évidemment des églises et de
l'état
et c'est une règle depuis l'application
de la loi de 1905 et cette règle est
très simple il ya toujours là aussi
beaucoup de confusion comme sur la
notion d'égalité
l'état est neutre il se tient à égale
distance de chacune des religions les
protège touche mais n'en favorise aucune
ensuite deuxième élément de réflexion
très simple il ya différence entre la
sphère privée et la sphère publique dans
la sphère privée on fait ce qu'on veut
dans la sphère publique à des règles il
ya des règles à l'école je m'honore
effectivement d'avoir été l'auteur d'un
rapport qui a permis à la demande de
jacques chirac et jean pierre raffarin à
l'époque
d'ouvrir le débat sur l'interdiction du
voile à l'école pourquoi et pourquoi
nous avons fait cela parce qu'il y avait
des menaces des menaces juridiques d
évolution constitutionnelle
un mouvement en turquie la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
avaient une conception assez élastique à
l'égard de ça il fallait une norme
supplémentaires il fallait protéger les
esprits en formation qui était à l'école
il fallait faire un sanctuaire nous y
sommes parvenus vous animez c'est
horrible et prochaine rentrée scolaire
ou être épouvantable ça va être un débat
insupportable et parents les enfants les
élèves les proviseurs les directeurs
d'école etc
il ya eu quoi une dizaine de cas et
ensuite la force de la loi s'est imposée
aux cadres républicains qui fait que
imaginer aujourd'hui le voile à l'école
n'est qu'une fantaisie de quelques-uns
qui veulent utiliser justement ce voile
comme un bélier contre le pilier de la
république
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de débat
là dessus donc il faut être ferme sur
ces sujets et la laïcité c'est pas un
élément poussiéreux ça n'a rien de
ringard c'est le modèle français qui est
notre façon à nous de trouver les voies
et moyens de nous respecter de nous
croiser et de vivre ensemble alors
certains veulent mettre la religion dans
le débat public
ils commettent une erreur moyenne
religion dans le débat public
mais on se porte et mais on se porte
mieux on protège ceux qui ont
l'espérance la ferveur et c'est notre
devoir de permettre à ceux qui ont cette
ferveur et cette espérance de pouvoir
trouver le chemin dans la sphère privée
de cette espérance et de pouvoir trouver
le chemin dans la sphère publique de
l'accompagnement d'un rôle citoyen c'est
autour de ces idées simples que la
république se construit c'est autour de
ces idées simples qu'elle doit également
se féconder jour après jour et c'est
autour de ces idées simples qu'elle doit
se transmettre de génération en
génération
la france ressemble à aucun autre pays
nous sommes un vieux pays une vieille
civilisation qui s'est construit depuis
deux siècles un peu plus elle se
construit autour de ce grand texte de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen du 26 août 1789 qui était juste
l'aspiration à plus de liberté et plus
de possibilité d'écrire son propre
chemin avec son propre bonheur et sa
propre vision et c'est cela que nous
devons transmettre à vous d'une part et
c'est cela que vous devrez transmettre
dans vos responsabilités également aux
générations qui vous succession d y
succèderont c'est un devoir
c'est une passion c'est une exigence
c'est ce que nous devons à nos aînés
c'est ce que nous devons à nos
contemporains
c'est ce que nous devons également
naturellement aux générations qui vont
soulever derrière vous et qui auront
aussi à avoir cette exigence chevillée
au corps d'être français et être
français c'est pas regarder ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis pour regarder ce
qui se passe aux etats unis
enfin le modèle américain il a rien à
voir même la définition de la loi n'a
rien à voir la loi aux états unis c'est
une somme d'intérêts particuliers
je suis noir j'ai des droits je suis pas
ni j'ai des droits je suis italien j'ai
des droits en france la loi c'est
l'expression de la volonté générale est
donc l'intérêt général n'est pas la
somme des intérêts particuliers
et c'est pour ça que tout autre modèle
n'est pas compatible avec la réalité du
modèle républicain
une fois qu'on a bien intégré cela alors
on peut imaginer quelles sont les
conditions de réconcilier les réussites
avec avec la république eh bien d'abord
il faut qu'on s'entende sur la
définition de ce qu'est ce qu'une
réussite
est ce qu'une réussite c'est réussir
dans la vie
ou est-ce que c'est réussir sa vie c'est
plutôt quand même réussir sa vie
qu'est ce qui vous fait plaisir quel est
votre talent comment vous pouvez le
développer comment imaginer l'épanouir
le faire partager au fond c'est ça
définir son propre bonheur imaginez-le
écrire personnellement avoir des cadres
protecteur et être libre de pouvoir le
faire
on est aujourd'hui dans une période de
restriction progressive un peu avec le
co vite bien sûr mais ça c'est pour se
protéger nos moines mais beaucoup dans
une ambiance généralisée autour d'un
recul des libertés
s'il ya bien un combat que les
républicains et que les jeunes
républicains doivent porter me
semble-t-il c'est celui de la liberté et
de la défense de la liberté de la
défense des libertés et de la défense de
la liberté de pouvoir écrire son
histoire de la manière dont on imagine
ce sera ça la réussite est l'une des
réussites pour les jeunes républicains
ce sera d'être les les faire éclairer
les porte étendards de cette notion de
liberté
voilà j'ai déjà été trop long c'est
problème c'est qu'avec un politique on
lui fit le micro il le prend il le rend
plus c'était juste de l'introduction je
laisse le soin à notre secrétaire
général à présent d'organiser le cadre
des débats
et comme convenu avec christian avec
toute l'équipe je suis disponible pour
répondre à toutes vos questions et comme
on dit par ailleurs en revanche dans une
d'assises parler sans haine et sans
crainte il ya pas de sujet tabou il n'y
a pas d'hôtel non plus après je lui
répondre ou pas mais ça vous le
comprendrez
merci cher françois on va donc passer à
l'exercice des questions réponses
les deux micros qui vont circuler dans
la salle vous vous lever pour vous
manifester
petite remarque les journalistes ne font
a priori pas partie des militants si
vous voulez poser des questions il table
à l'extérieur qui vous permet de prendre
votre adhésion républicain et dès que
vous aurez pris votre adhésion
républicain vous pourrez avec grand
bonheur poser toutes les questions que
wise relégables ils souhaitent poser la
première question c'est à toi alors je
m'appelle thomas savy air des vidéos de
pyrénées on en parle souvent qui est un
problème avec l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui des savoirs qui se
transmettent pas une éducation qui se
transmet ce pack istres ou qui ne se
transmet pas vardon un devoir de mémoire
aussi un devoir civique qui ne se
transmettent pas non plus est-ce que
vous partager l'analyse qu'il faut
considérablement changé voir transformer
l'éducation nationale trouver d'autres
moyens trouver une autre manière de la
présenter
trouver une autre moyen d'études
d'apprendre de faire apprendre de
transmettre des valeurs et des idées
parce qu'aujourd'hui on va pas se cacher
selon moi mais je pense qu'on partage
ici beaucoup l'éducation nationale a
échoué à la faille même s'il ya plein de
personnes de bonne volonté
plein de personnes de bonne volonté par
dont l'éducation nationale elle a échoué
donc quelles alternatives proposées vous
merci merci pour ta question je pense
qu'on prenne une seconde question en
vendeuse et c'est françois répondre
mademoiselle sur ma gauche qui doit donc
être votre droite juste la levée ou
mademoiselle madame je sais plus comment
on dit bonjour à tous les publics un val
de marne alors pour moi c'est l'état
doit garantir une équité de traitement
quel que soit le milieu d'origine et le
milieu social l'égalité des chances va
plus loin que l'égalité des droits
suivants comment garantir donc l'égalité
des chances et comment réconcilier
république et réussite des jeunes
merci merci beaucoup françois sur la
question de
l'éducation est sûre ceux ci sont
d'ailleurs pour partie liés puisque la
promesse républicaine de garantir
l'égalité des chances c'est à
l'éducation nationale qu'elle se forge à
l'école au collège et au lycée
donc tout se joue là pour avoir cette
confusion naturelle entre la certitude
d'avoir les mêmes droits et la même
possibilité d'accéder d'accéder à ce que
l'on souhaite et pas un sentiment de
discrimination l'éducation nationale on
doit la vérité de dire que c'est un
ministre extrêmement difficile ça
représente déjà la moitié des
fonctionnaires de l'état
je sache toutefois pour prendre déjà la
dimension de ce que représente vous avez
le budget de l'état la moitié du budget
de l'état c'est du fonctionnement et à
l'intérieur de ce budget fonctionnement
la moitié du budget de fonctionnement
c'est l'éducation nationale donc on ne
peut pas dire que la république n'est
pas produit d'effets or ni sur le plan
des ressources humaines ni sur le plan
des moyens financiers pour se donner la
possibilité de transmettre ce qu'il faut
à chacune des étapes de la construction
d'un écolier n'a collégiens des lycéens
de savoir dans un encadrement protecteur
une belle écoles les collèges les lycées
etc
donc c'est bien un problème de fond et
on a sur ce sujet travailler de très
nombreuses années sur des propositions
on a contesté à une époque les instituts
universitaires de formation des maîtres
tout sur le même moule qui s'alignait
avec une doctrine
on ne se lève pas content le professeur
arrive puis ensuite s'étaler sur plus
rapidement et de manière plus récentes
sur la théorie des genres et puis un peu
plus tard sur les écritures inclusive
c'est pas notre truc ça faut être clair
non on est assez conservateur mais on
n'est pas conservateur on est
conservateur pour ceux qui marchent et
qu'est ce qui marche à une époque et qui
marchent plus aujourd'hui qui marchaient
à l'époque c'était les cours d'éducation
civique ce qui marchait à une époque
c'était le sentiment que le cadre
général protecteur des enseignants était
de compléter aussi l'éducation des
parents sur le savoir faire les bonnes
valeurs la politesse le respect le
devoir la droiture le courage le travail
c'est pas des valeurs exclusivement de
droite quand on est à droite on est un
peu plus attaché mais mais
mais ce sont des valeurs universelles et
profondément républicaines on s'est
éloigné de cela et je dois la vérité là
aussi de dire que le magistère hollande
avec les deux ministres qu'il y a eu si
du côté de vincent peillon on peut lui
reconnaître cet attachement à la laïcité
il n'y a pas que la laïcité et nous
avions fait voter la loi donc il n'y a
été que le défenseur de l'expression de
l'application de cette volonté générale
qui fut quasiment à l'unanimité une loi
qui interdit le voile à l'école merdoie
dans sa il n'a pas fait grand chose
en revanche vallaud belkacem je la cite
une deuxième fois sera la dernière fois
elle a eu quand même par son discours
par son organisation par les débats
qu'elle a ouvert une responsabilité dans
la dégradation de la compréhension de ce
qu'on attendait notre école et je le dis
pas pour la faire siffler même si c'est
aussi un droit que vous avez dans cette
salle je je je je le dis je le dis parce
que lorsque j'ai été une réunion avec
elle et qu'elle a développé cette
théorie de l'égalité réelle
je comprenais pas ce que disait je ne
comprenais rien de ce que me disait je
dis ça veut dire quoi
et là elle est tombé de l'armoire on
aurait dit je ne sais pas cette bande
dessinée les lapins crétins qui écoute
la tong en pensant qu'elle réponde à son
téléphone
elle ne comprenait pas ce que je lui
disais elle ne comprenait pas cette
question et on ne se comprenait pas du
tout on n'était pas sur la même planète
ce que l'on attend de l'éducation c'est
d'abord et avant tout les transmissions
de la valeur de république
c'est ensuite un enseignement simple et
est décidé simple il ya un parcours
jusqu'au cm2 et puis il ya un parcours
pour le collège et puis un parcours pour
le hisser et ensuite il faut être armé
armes et pragmatique
l'entreprise n'est pas l'ennemi de
l'éducation quand on entend des discours
de membres du corps enseignant qui
refuse qu'un chef d'entreprise puissent
expliquer comment il fonctionne
mais on tombe de l'armoire nancy mais
comment on va préparer nos jeunes
justement à s'insérer sur tissu
économique en espérant que ce soit
plutôt dans le secteur marchand que dans
le secteur non marchand parce que ça
créera de la richesse tout ça ce sont
des questions qui autour de ce sujet
nous amène à réfléchir
moi je suis pas contre 1 beaucoup
d'idées que blogueur a développé chacun
sait les liens qui nous unissent on se
connaît depuis toujours on a grandi de
la même manière et on a eu les mêmes
valeurs et on est attaché justement à
ces valeurs
mais mais est-ce qu'il a les moyens
aujourd'hui de mener à bien la politique
telle que il pouvait l'envisager
en tout cas j'aime mieux les rentrées
actuelle qu'il ya quelques années
moi j'ai aimé la rentrée scolaire même
si elle a été difficile avec un peu de
musique avec des chorales avec la
lecture de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme avec la lecture
justement des valeurs de la république
voilà ça ce sont des avancées
j'aime bien l'idée qu'on transmette les
fables de la fontaine andy mais c'est
affreusement réactionnaire et c'est non
dans ce qui est réactionnaire c'est de
considérer que des idées qui nous ont
emmenés dans le mur issus de 68 sont
encore d'actualité
sa série actionnaires ce qui est moderne
c'est de considérer que ce qui a permis
à nos parents d'être des gens dit une
responsable respectable et citoyens sur
la base de valeurs qui leur ont été
transmises peuvent être à nouveau
prodigués aux jeunes générations qui
sont actuellement à l'école et ça c'est
pas réactionnaires ça c'est d'avenir ça
c'est progressiste et ça c'est
intelligent pour le pays
c'est un élément de réponse pour partie
à la à deuxième question sur l'égalité
des chances et l'égalité des chances
c'est aussi le devoir de la république à
chacune des étapes et sur chacun des
sujets de trouver les éléments de de
compensation je n'ai jamais été un fan
de la discrimination positive je le dis
franchement et je suis plutôt sur le
phénomène d'intégration républicaine
profonde mais quand il ya des correctifs
à faire il faut pouvoir le faire ça a
été fait par exemple sur la place des
femmes dans la société je t'ai pas
favorable à ce qu'une loin interviennent
pour imposer en quelque sorte d
pourcentage de femmes mais c'était
devenu nécessaire sur ce sujet là comme
sur tant d'autres il faut accepter
d'avoir des correctifs mais pas remettre
en cause le bloc qui constitue en
quelque sorte qu'on appelle la statue
intérieures de la république
merci alors question en obama gauche ici
ouais euh pardon il avait dit je vous en
prie monsieur françois baroin bonjour
sacha gaillard maire adjoint au sein de
la ville de saint cloud dans le 92
vous avez une vision pour la france vous
avez ces valeurs que vous défendez corps
et âme nous sommes beaucoup ici à les
partager
vous avez précisé être libre de répondre
aux questions qui vous sont posées
elle al'air d'intervenir bien tard votre
question beaucoup sommes ici présents
aussi pour vous entendre sur ce sujet
peut-être je ne sais pas
serez vous candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
françois je te propose qu'on ne prenne
pas de seconde question qui pousserait
pourront peut-être directement celle ci
ça c'est un truc de pradier il me
cherche au téléphone depuis une semaine
et je lui réponds pas dans le coup il
dit tiens je vais te manger perdu un
pari j'avais parié que personne ne te
poses la question
bon je vais je vais je vais pas vous
répondre je vais pas vous répondre parce
que on est ici je trouve extraordinaire
qu'on est ce un rassemblement de jeunes
n'y a pas un parti politique est
aujourd'hui capable de rassembler ou
tout jeune dans une même salle
je prends pour répondre parce que si on
est en convalescence
nous sommes au lendemain d'une belle
victoire aux municipales dans la
construction d'un projet qui va aider
nos représentants à conforter la
position de gérard larcher d'ici le mois
de septembre pour être justement aux
avant-postes du débat démocratique sur
ce qu'il faut faire pour le pays
je vais pas vous répondre parce que si
nous sommes entre nous dans cette salle
à partager nos valeurs on ne fait pas
abstraction de ce qui se passe dans le
pays et que j'ai pas croiser une
personne à 3 ou ailleurs en dehors de ma
famille qui pose la question un peu
comme vous matin midi et soir
mais qui me parle de la présidentielle
on parle de la peur on parle de
l'organisation parle de la rentrée
scolaire
on parle des entreprises on parle du
prendre heures laurence et ce sera
efficace pas efficace
on parle de l'avenir à trois mois on
parle de l'avenir à six mois on parle de
l'avenir un an on parle pas encore de la
présidentielle maintenant que le moment
venu celui que j'ai fixé et je ne
bougerai pas qui sera l'automne m'amène
à avoir ce devoir vis-à-vis de ma
famille politique d'apporter une réponse
puisque cette question vous poser
d'autres cela pose je le ferai en temps
et en heure en responsabilité avec la
passion du pays avec la passion ma
famille et avec la volonté de tout faire
pour être un facteur d'union et pas de
divisions donc je répondrai le moment
venu à cette question je vous remercie
de l'avoir posée et je suis
naturellement sensible à vos
encouragements
à
je suis toujours extrêmement gênée
d'arrêter des applaudissements tu as la
parole est joué très bien accueilli bon
peut que se réjouir de cette joie
bonjour monsieur baroin chéque trouvé ce
bonjour je suis élu dont le 15e choix
liste d'agnès evren et eux fait le bon
choix
je ne peux que partager le message que
vous lui avez fait passer tout à l'heure
et d'ailleurs même françois-xavier
bellamy rappeler sa ténacité
ce matin parler de fidélité tout à
l'heure et c'était vraiment une grande
chance voilà pour agnès
c'est très bien de l'avoir fait on
t'écoute la deuxième partie donc vous
êtes président de la mef dont 4 est
relié au rôle de mère qui comme on le
voit est peut-être en devant de
l'actualité ces derniers temps avec
toutes les dernières crises qu'on a pu
vivre la crise des gilet jaune la crise
plus récemment toutes les crises qu'on
peut voir les violences qui a contre les
maires on n'a pas d'autorités on n'a pas
de réponse aux violences que vivent les
maires au quotidien et puis celle là il
mène vers une question plus large d'une
crise d'un désespoir que je remarque une
crise républicaine une absence d'espoir
entre la population et la république et
c'est ce que je vois au sein cette crise
et gilet jaune et gilet jaune se sentent
trahis les mères se sentent abandonnés
par la république
certaines communautés se sentent
délaissés par la communauté nationale et
c'est pour ça que j'en viens à cette
notion de vraiment de désespoir et sans
parler vous avez parlé de pas mal de
mesures d'action qu'on peut avoir on a
parlé d' autorité on a parlé de
différentes notions n'est plus sur une
question d'incarnation comment est-ce
qu'on peut redonner à la population
l'envi d'espérer des déterminés à agir
avec tous avec les élus avec les acteurs
privés avec les acteurs publics en
confiance et sans perpétuellement
s'opposer merci beaucoup
françois lespérance
l'espérance ou et bien sûr vous avez
bien fait de citer françois xavier
bellamy voilà un homme de grand talent
qui est mené un combat difficile et
courageuse et qui est je lui demande de
bien l'avoir en tête n'est aucunement
responsable du score qui a été le nôtre
au moment du scrutin européen ça remonte
à bien plus loin et il ne fut
malheureusement que le porte parole de
ceux pour lesquels nous devons tirer des
leçons est allé sur le chemin de la
compréhension des raisons pour
lesquelles il faut pas les renouveler
mais ça c'est un autre sujet ce sera
pour plus tard sur l'espérance et sur
les capacités de travailler ensemble
l'état du pays et est extrêmement
préoccupant il faut il faut être
conscient pour ceux qui sont comme nous
engagée depuis de très nombreuses années
au service de notre passion qui est de
servir l'intérêt général d'être dans
l'action publique
nous avons eu les uns et les autres d
honneur immense immense irremplaçable
inouïe même d'avoir pour ce qui me
concerne la confiance de jacques chirac
pour lequel je me suis engagé en
politique et d'avoir la confiance de
nicolas sarkozy dont j'admire chaque
jour la force vitale l'énergie et le
rôle qu'il fut le sien pour aider notre
pays à protéger les français à protéger
leur monnaie et à garantir justement le
rôle et la place de la france dans
l'europe
ce sont des sons des modèles et ce sont
des repères chacun à l'âme à leur
manière et chacun dans dans l'horreur
qualité mais dans les deux qualités de
ces deux hommes d'état que comme
d'autres ici j'ai eu la chance de
fréquenter pour lesquelles j'ai eu
l'honneur de travailler
il y avait dans le regard une humanité
une compassion sincère intérêt pour ce
que vous dit l'autre n'y a jamais eu
l'arrogance
on l'a dit nicolas sarkozy en a eu bien
tort y a pas plus affectif que nicolas
sarkozy
il ya pas plus humain y a pas plus
généreux et quant à jacques chirac
j'ai vu - jacques chirac pendant trois
heures mettre tout côté et passer des
coups de fil pour récupérer le tuyau
d'arrosage du fils de son jardinier qui
risquait de perdre son travail parce
qu'il avait perdu malheureusement son
outil de travail
c'est quelqu'un qui pouvait passer des
heures et des heures sincèrement aider
l'autre donc c'est d'abord et avant tout
une attitude quand on est au pouvoir et
aux responsabilités c'est pas c'est pas
vient me chercher
vous venez me chercher c'est pas si on
prend l'exemple de cette semaine c'est
détestable ou sais pas c'est
irresponsable ou cépages traverse la rue
je vous trouve un boulot
voyez c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas ce
sentiment d' arrogance qui se dégage est
ce sentiment d' arrogance qui se dégage
de ce pouvoir
c'est un sentiment qui écarte qui sépare
les gens plus qu'il ne les rassemble
or ce dont on a besoin aujourd'hui c'est
de les rassembler et le pays et en a
beaucoup de mal à respirer
ce pouvoir n'est pas que responsable
enfin il n'est pas non plus
irresponsable de tout ce qui se passe
dans le pays
quand on additionne les actes de
terrorisme pour lesquels le procès
charlish ouvre pendant deux mois quand
on additionne les gilets jaunes
mouvement social inédit parti je le
rappelle d'une mesure fiscale
typiquement budgétaire et comptable
alignés sur une doctrine de ceux qui
veulent justement imposer leur mode de
vie augmente la fiscalité du gasoil
parce qu'on veut plus diesel on veut
plus de voitures on veut plus de 4,4 et
on veut vivre
hartnett à vélo d'ailleurs on peut plus
faire que ça d'ailleurs les vélos les
trottinettes
ils n'ont pas de feu rouge tous les
autres s'arrêtent je sais même pas
comment y a pas plus d'accidents
enfin et on veut vivre comme à paris
partout en france
là cette mesure comptable d'une vision
doctrinaire a amené la france à
organiser un mouvement social comme
jamais mais il faut ne pas connaître la
france pour s'obstiner sur ce sujet et
le pouvoir s'est obstinée sur cette
mesure jusqu'à lâcher à la fin et puis
ensuite j'ai vu les 80 kilomètres heure
c'est ces deux mesures qui font les
gilet jaune mais moi je vous le dit hein
à ceux qui s'interrogent sur le thème
quand même
macron il plaît à droite il pleurait au
centre c'est une politique que vous
n'avez pas eu le courage de faire jour
pendant deux trois exemples mais très
simple d'abord nous on n'aurait pas pris
ces mesures sur le fuel et on n'aurait
pas pris ces mesures sur le 80 km heure
parce que nous on sait que plus de la
moitié des français vivent dans des
communes de moins de 10000 habitants
nous on sait que près de 40% des
français vivent dans des communes de
moins de 2500 habitants et forcément
dans les bassins de vie démographiques
économiques font que la moitié des gens
d'un département rural vivent dans
l'agglomération va vous faire 30 40 50
km et donc on sait qu'il faut plutôt
prendre sa voiture surtout l'hiver quand
la nuit tombe dans un grand fracas à
16h30 au mois de novembre qui fait main
3 avec le gel arrive on va pas prendre
son vélo
on va pas prendre cette trottinette et
on va pas vivre comme à paris on dit oui
mais macron quand même sur le plan
fiscal fait une politique de droite
d'ailleurs
les électeurs de droite il aime bien on
dit regarde l isf et même encore des
gens qui disent ouais tiens lui la
réforme eliès f d'abord nous on a
réformé isf et nicolas sarkozy a réformé
dsf
il se trouvait était ministre du budget
c'est moi qui ai fait la réforme on a
monté le seuil d'entrée de l'isf f il y
avait cinq tourne en effet plus que deux
elle était acceptée par tous
il y avait les fort de solidarité de
ceux qui ont le plus et qu'il acceptait
pour financer les politiques publiques à
l'égard des plus fragiles avec un des
taux qui était moins prohibitifs et donc
moins punitifs et moins pénalisant qui
poussait les gens à partir à l'étranger
et enfin un seuil d'entrée qui évitait
aux gens qui avaient construit leur
patrimoine en devenant propriétaire ne
pas être puni par un nouvel impôt tout
simplement lié à l'évolution du marché
de l'immobilier à paris ou ailleurs on
l'a fait à cette réforme
sauf que hollande est arrivé on a perdu
l'élection et que le premier est la
première décision dans le collectif
budgétaire post hollande ça a été de
supprimer cette réforme nous permettrait
de rappeler qu'à l'époque le conseiller
économique de françois hollande
c'était emmanuel macron nous permettait
de vous rappeler que ensuite été
secrétaire général aux affaires
économiques ont pas mais très pour
rappeler qu'il était ministre de
l'économie également et que rien n'a
changé sur le sujet or dit oui mais la
réforme et les sf je dis parce que c'est
tellement emblématique justement de ce
qui semble-t-il c'est par la droite et
la gauche c'est absurde
la réforme de l'isf c'est pas une année
c'est pas une suppression de l'sf c'est
c'est une logique mais alors vraiment
comptable et budgétaire où il a repris
le prêt-à-penser de ce que dit bercy
depuis toujours l'argent qui est dans
l'immobilier est un argent qui dort il
ne sert pas l'économiste qui sert le
pays c'est l'économie donc il faut punir
ceux qui sont propriétaires et donc la
réforme de macron et je comprends même
pas qu'il ya encore des gens de droite
qui distingue c'est super la forme du
sfc punir les propriétaires
il a puni les propriétaires on est
propriétaire surtout pour des gens de
droite ça peut être un projet de vie ça
peut être un projet pour sa vie mais ça
peut être aussi un projet de vie
d'accumuler du patrimoine pour avoir la
joie le bonheur de se dire la génération
à laquelle j'appartiens apporte un petit
plus à celle qui sera derrière c'est de
transmettre ce patrimoine à ses enfants
de faire en sorte que les droits de
succession soit pas aussi élevé le faire
en sorte que cette fiscalité ne soit pas
punitive et donc si j'ai envie de
devenir propriétaire
je grandisse ou macron j'ai du mal et
d'ailleurs il s'est pas arrêté là il a
supprimé la taxe d'habitation dit il là
aussi une idée technocratique comptable
budgétaire sur bercy je suis d'autant
plus à l'aise pour le dire que j'ai
dirigé bercy et que toutes ces notes on
les a eus en temps et en heure sauf que
nous on a fait du filtre politique et
que il compte même pas les points y
regarder des ah bah tiens la direction
l'a dit c'est proposer ça devient un
projet la taxe d'habitation
je vais vous dire il ça répond quand
même directement à votre question c'est
la rupture du lien entre les habitants
et son territoire l'impôt la taxe
d'habitation c'était je suis
contribuable local je vis à trois je
paye un impôt pour peut d'ailleurs c'est
pas bougé depuis 21 ans est une ville
magnifique gens se déroule le
développement touristique et je précise
d'ailleurs que manchester city avait
racheté son club de foot qui lui donne
beaucoup d'espoir et d'ambition pour les
prochaines années
vous avez là bas d'ailleurs le secteur
sauvegardé d'un seul tenant le plus beau
des maisons à pans de bois du 16e siècle
etc etc
soyez bienvenue à 3 il faudra venir la
plus belle ville de france et je suis
con tribuables à 3 je sais à qui je
m'adresse je vais voir le maire j'ai
besoin de crèches d'écoles les routes
sur dégueulasse il faut d'éclairage
public etc
je sais à qui je m'adresse la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
d'avoir sa valeur il a pris de l'argent
si la supprimer un impôt qui lui
appartenait pas c'est aux collectivités
locales
ensuite ça a été immédiatement effacées
malheur dans la seconde par
l'augmentation de 20 points de csg 1,7
pour cent vingt points de csg on n'aura
jamais fait les 20 points de csg sa
punit les personnes âgées
ça a planté le pouvoir d'achat ça
affaiblit l'économie et la taxe
d'habitation a eu en plus comme objectif
de recentraliser par la nationalisation
des impôts locaux
elles ont dit oui mais regardez les
impôts de production à la sortie d'été
dans le plan de relance les impôts de
production c'est la même chose on nous
dit mais vaqueront veut re localiser
veut aider les entreprises à relocaliser
il a raison tout le monde le souhaite à
commencer par les entreprises sauf que
là encore il va supprimer l'impôt de
production qui constitue la liberté
locale la liberté locale et il va
nationaliser les impôts de production
pour recentraliser alors que si le
problème c'est drôle que localisés c'est
pas les 70 milliards sur les impôts de
production qui permettent de financer
les intercommunalités les régions une
partie des villes les politiques
publiques de proximité c'est les charges
sociales
c'est 70 milliards d'un côté pour les
impôts de production c'est près de 400
milliards pour les charges sociales
donc si le projet politique c'est drôle
localisés dans ce cas là il faut
s'attaquer aux charges sociales mais non
merci n'en veux pas parce que ces
financements des comptes publics
donc la politique elle est celle ci je
pourrais vous prendre la politique de
l'apl la mesure de la baisse des 5 euro
qui a atteint le pouvoir d'achat des
allocataires de l'apl qui a mis en l'air
le projet des bailleurs sociaux et qui
nourrit devant nous un mur qui sera
extraordinairement difficile à franchir
qui est le retard pris dans la
construction pour l'accession à la
location et la propriété dans le domaine
social comme dans le domaine privé et on
dit tiens vous auriez fait la même
politique je vous dis tout de suite on
n'aurait pas fait la même politique
je suis et sinon fait pas de politique
absolument convaincu qu'on aurait fait
mieux et on aurait certainement évité
les sujets qui font qu'aujourd'hui avec
le co vide où l'état n'a pas été à la
hauteur
macron ne peut pas dire que l'état
résister soit l'état qu'à résister c'est
les français qui ont été courageux sont
les entreprises qui ont été à
l'initiative
ce sont les maires qui ont été
protecteur ce sont les régions qui ont
été à gilles ce sont les départements
qui ont garanti la solidarité nationale
mais l'état n'a pas été à
ni en anticipation ni en prévision unis
en protection donc pour ceux qui veulent
faire de la politique
et pour ceux qui parmi vous veulent
s'engager dans les prochains combats
je peux vous dire il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire pour amener
les gens sur le chemin du partage de la
faveur de ce que veut dire être fiers
d'être républicain
merci françois je pense qu'on prenne une
question supplémentaire alors une jeune
femme qui masque j'avoue que j'ai un peu
de mal mais vous voyez mieux que moi
pardon est ce qu'il ya une jeune fille
voilà en bas dans la pénombre
s'il vous plaît c'est ce qu'on appelle
de la discrimination positive mais on
est très heureux de la discrimination
positive
vous avez la parole bonjour du coup je
m'appelle emad moi je suis originaire de
vichy dans l'allier et je suis parti du
coup à paris pour mes études et j'aurais
voulu vous poser une question en lien
avec les territoires parce qu'on voit
que souvent quand ses associés en fait à
l'enseignement supérieur
les jeunes sont obligés partir de leur
territoire contre sont plus enclavées
plus ruraux et donc on voit une perte de
dynamisme de tous ces territoires avec
des termes qui tombent parfois des gones
elle du vide etc
et du coup j'aimerais savoir comment
faire pour que ces territoires qui sont
aujourd'hui en perte de dynamisme
comment vous feriez vous et quelles sont
vos idées pour que ces territoires qui
sont en perte de dynamisme soit plus
seulement des terres de départ en fait
mais toi aussi des terres de retour et
que les jeunes peuvent venir puissent
revenir dans leur territoire
c'est un sujet
c'est un sujet considérables et qui
touche en fait toutes les villes ça si
on me le permettez juste pour vous
répondre brièvement je vais vous dire ce
qu'on a fait à 3 puisqu'on était
exactement dans le cas de vichy je suis
élu maire pour la première fois il ya
donc 157 ans nous sommes en 95 et il y
avait un peu plus de 2000 étudiants les
étudiants pourraient aller jusqu'au bac
il y avait peut-être une prépa il y
avait un nid été et c'était très
difficile de poursuivre ses études dont
qui partait à reims à dijon ou à paris
comme vous et moi même si c'est un peu
plus près c'était ça et donc la
stratégie que l'on a mis en place on a
dit il ya trois priorités
on est un peu enclavé nous on a pas
train électrique n ya pas de tgv donc
notre combat c'est d'en terminer avec
les micheline diesel et et c2 d'avoir
des des fils électriques nous permettent
de nous relier à paris c'était le
développement économique
parce que on était dans la
mono-industrie stèle textile l'opulence
et 60 70 et puis après les accords
multifibres l'état sous la gauche a
sacrifié une partie nos industries
notamment le textile et la sidérurgie à
l'époque dans les négociations
internationales au bénéfice des dragons
du sud est asiatique
c'est comme ça que le coût unitaire du
travail a explosé chez nous et qu'il a
baissé chez eux c'est comme ça qu'on a
perdu les l'emploi les emplois et à
trois on a perdu 1000 emplois par an
pendant 20 ans tout le monde travaille
dans le textile chez lacoste
mon masque c'est pas une fantaisie
cosmétiques esthétique d'un dandy
parisien c'est le remerciement aux
ouvrières qui ont offert 75 villes
masque au moment du coc vide en allant
travailler à l'usiné avec le petit
crocodile de lacoste pour dire on va
aider les citoyens
et donc tout le monde travaillait dans
ces entreprises et on a perdu
évidemment ces emplois mais c'était
beaucoup de souffrance sociale donc le
développement économique deuxième axe
prioritaire de développement du
territoire
on met plus tous ses oeufs dans le même
panier on essaye de diversifier l'offre
ont créé des parcs de développement
économique ont créé des centres
d'entreprises on adapte la fiscalité
quand on pouvait le faire on essaye
d'être attractif
c'était très important mais pour faire
venir des entreprises elles ont aussi
besoin de main d'oeuvre de matière grise
et deux cadres sur lesquels à terme
elles peuvent s'appuyer ou d'ouvriers
sur lequel elles peuvent également se
coordonner pour créer de la richesse
pour l'entreprise et on s'est dit
l'enseignement supérieur va être une
priorité et on l'a mis comme priorité on
est passé de 2000 étudiants aujourd'hui
à près de 13000 sur trois pour une ville
de 62 mille habitants rapporté à la
population
c'est l'équivalent de ce que vous voyez
en termes de densité étudiante à nantes
à rennes ou à lille et on le fait en
investissement on le fait en
fonctionnement on le fait dans tous les
secteurs
on ne néglige aucune écoute alors on
bénéficie de la proximité parisienne
s'est pas vichy mais je pense qu'à
partir du moment où on le fait est que
tout le monde accompagne dans ce cas là
c'est un axe stratégique de
développement
il faut le faire avec la région il faut
le faire avec les départements il faut
des participations croisées mais il faut
l'affirmer comme priorité est d'ailleurs
l'enseignement supérieur c'est un sujet
de décentralisation majeur on peut pas
continuer à avoir un état qui au titre
de sa stratégie
là encore dirigé par bercy dit ben tout
ce qui va être financement de pôle
d'excellence
c'est à paris ou dans les six métropoles
tout ce qui va être les centres d'études
et laboratoires les technopoles on va
les financer uniquement pour les six
métropoles
c'est une erreur parmi tant d'autres de
concentrer tous et toutes les richesses
dans des petits bassins de vie où les
gens s'agglutinent s'accumulent
additionne les difficultés sociales si
fun la richesse des autres prennent la
jeunesse d'autres territoires et ensuite
ils ne reviennent plus il faut faire
exactement l'inversé
il faut faire la verse sur
l'enseignement supérieur il faut faire
la verse sur la santé il faut faire la
verse sur la culture il faut faire la
verse sur le sport il faut faire la
verse sur le logement
il faut faire la verse dans d'autres
secteurs il faut une nouvelle
organisation des pouvoirs
public l'état est obèse il est asphyxié
il ya plus personne dans les
départements christian jacob parlait de
déconcentration
pourquoi ça a échoué à au moment du coup
vite pourquoi sur les mères qui ont pris
le pouvoir
pourquoi on a été à l'initiative parce
qu'on a constaté en quelques jours qu'on
avait plus de correspondants que les ars
était lointaine que y'avait pas de
masque qu'on pouvait pas protégé donc la
santé le maire doit être au coeur du
dispositif pour assemblée publique
privée et la santé
peut-être que comme en allemagne les
régions doivent avoir le dernier mot sur
le cadre général
s'il y avait une décentralisation en
matière de santé est ce que ça aurait
été un confinement dans tout le pays
alors que c'était ma région
ile-de-france et les autres france qui
était principalement touchés on aurait
pu laisser vivre les autres régions
normalement et puis ensuite protéger
celles qui étaient plus directement
touché
donc on serait allé sur le terrain du
pragmatisme sur le logement on peut pas
continuer d'avoir justement là même
appel à neuilly où il ya je peux
peut-être pas tout à fait 14 15 % de
logements sociaux car il y en a plus
qu'on ne croit que à 3 vous avez 40 % de
logements sociaux ou dans d'autres
villes où on dépasse les 50%
il faut une politique adaptée au
territoire la culture la culture ces
trois idées simples c'est le patrimoine
c'est l'aide à la création c'est l'égal
accès pour tous à la culture est ce que
l'état avec sous tout petit budget peut
répondre à ces trois objectifs
prioritaires qui entretient le
patrimoine seront les communaux qui
favorise le financement de l'égal accès
pour tous à la culture par des
médiathèques des centres de résidences
d'artistes etc sont les maires qui
finance les associations culturelles
sont les maires mais il faut leur donner
le pouvoir et en gardant une ligne
nationale vous pouvez avoir la même
politique sur le sport qui finance le
sport c'est les maires qui finance les
associations c'est les maires qui est
propriétaire des complexes sportifs
c'est les maires et fort de tout cela
l'état centralisateur arrogant pour 130
ou les pouvoirs constate à regret
l'échec de l'existence d'un ministère ne
veut pas lâcher le financement des
associations créer une agence nationale
du sport financés on ne sait où sont
transférés véritablement les
responsabilités à ceux qui les exercent
déjà je pourrais prendre le domaine du
social jeu pour reprendre d'autres
secteurs si cela et ça c'est un grand
enjeu décentralisation déconcentration
si les termes qui nous sont familiers
mais qui ne parlent pas aux français
en revanche qui fait quoi de quelle
manière et est ce qu'on vous propose
vous propose s'il ira dans le bon sens
et vous serez mieux garantis mieux
protéger et vous saurez à qui vous
adresser alors oui c'est autour de ces
sujets là qu'il faut travailler on va
prendre la dernière question merci
bonjour je m'appelle eloi d'oise et je
viens de douai dans le nord chez
étudiant en droit
donc moi la question que vous posez une
chute baroin donc on en a déjà parlé
hier pour l'activité mais c'est
l'intelligence de la main et du cou
qu'est ce que vous avez comme
proposition pour revaloriser les
filières technologiques et les filières
professionnelles question vous vous
pensez qu'on peut faire pour redorer le
blason par exemple des compagnons du
tour de france peut faire pour que
l'artisanat en france redevienne le fer
de lance de notre industrie de car si
françois ce sera le mot de conclusion on
lan la réponse est non mais elle est
super cette dernière question alors nous
on est très très attachés on plaide
depuis très longtemps sur des idées qui
n'ont pas toujours été mises en oeuvre
ça progresse un peu mais enfin c'est
quand même marginale il ya un problème
de financement mais il faut donner toute
la formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage et l'emploi aux régions
il faut donner la formation
professionnelle l'apprentissage et
l'emploi c'est-à-dire l'accompagnement
individuel dans un bassin d'emploi aux
régions quitte à skier en partenariat
avec les communes les intercommunalités
etc
ensuite il ya une question d'entrer
effectivement dans dans la formation
moi à titre personnel je rien
n'impressionne plus que quelqu'un qui a
un talent de la main rien ne
m'impressionnent plus qu'à menuisier
qu'un charpentier qu'un plombier je suis
incompétent je suis nul
j'ai peur de mettre le feu à ma maison
quand je touche un truc d'ailleurs je
touche plus rien puisque je casse tout
enfin bref c'est un talent dont je ne
dispose pas
j'en ai très peu d'autres par ailleurs
aussi il faut être lucide sur soi même
mais mais je n'ai pas celui ci est jeu
et je pense que c'est extraordinaire
mais il faut le faire à ces jeunes ne
serait ce que pour libérer des jeunes
qui rame qui s'ouvre il souffre en cm2
ils souffrent en sixième il souffre en
cinquième ils sont à la ramasse ils sont
mal regardé par leurs copains tout
simplement parce que ils ne sont pas
épanoui tout le monde peut pas faire de
la chaise pendant des heures tout le
monde ne peut pas s'investir dans des
matières d'abstraction tout le monde ne
peut pas avoir une
une passion pour l'histoire les
mathématiques la géographie mais tout le
monde ne peut pas être un homme
talentueux pour construire des maisons
pour construire des ponts pour
construire des routes et ce talent il
doit pouvoir s'exprimer très vite
d'abord parce qu'à cet âge-là ils
s'expriment beaucoup plus rapidement et
avec un grand potentiel et à cet âge là
et s'il est accompagné valoriser ces
merveilleux pour un jeune de s'épanouir
justement autant que ses petits
camarades de route
ensuite il ya l'accompagnement les
compagnons du devoir c'est l'excellence
de l'excellence nous on a une maison des
compagnons du devoir à 3 parce que
justement on a une vieille ville de
france et comme je vous le disais on a
le secteur sauvegardé d'un seul tenant
donc on a parmi les meilleurs
charpentier au monde probablement les
meilleurs menuisier et on sait ce que
cela veut dire
mais vous avez aussi d'autres structures
vous avez l'outil en main qui est un
réseau extraordinaire associative qui
très vite et très tôt complète justement
les manques de l'éducation nationale à
travers du périscolaire qui permet à des
jeunes de se découvrir et d'avoir cette
cheminement la donnons les moyens à
l'outil en main de généraliser d'être
présent dans toutes les villes de france
dans toutes les communes aux côtés de
l'organisation du système périscolaire
pour permettre à des jeunes d'avoir au
moins quelques heures chaque jour un peu
plus pour définir son talent écrire son
bonheur et être accompagnés par des
adultes responsables
c'est c'est une certaine idée aussi de
ce que veut dire la promesse
républicaine et peu importe l'histoire
qui nous amènera à vivre ensemble dans
les semaines les mois et les années qui
viennent de toute façon je serai
toujours là mais ce qui sera surtout
toujours là c'est que cette passion de
la république est en vous c'est un
devoir
il n'y a rien de plus beau que de voir
cette salle on ne voit plus que vos
regards mais on imagine vos sourires et
on espère également votre bonne humeur
il n'y a rien de plus beau que cet
engagement vous fait il n'y a rien de
plus beau que de servir la république et
rien de plus beau que d'exercer des
mandats et rien de plus beau que d'être
un militant
les militants ils doivent être honorés
ils doivent être respectées nous les
élus on leur doit tout on leur doit tout
et on ne l'oublient pas
et dans les années passées certains qui
ont fait d'autres choix par opportunisme
il faut dire qu'ils avaient peut-être
lui le dictionnaire des girouettes et du
maréchal têtards qui concluait son
parcours en ayant servi tous les régimes
après les avoir triés travailler avec la
même constance professionnels il est
vrai qu'en retournant sa veste
on attrape jamais un rhume et bien
laissé le maréchal de toutes tes tard
deux côtés restez comme vous êtes
justement avec votre veste vous habib
république un profond fier regardez tout
le monde droit devant avec beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup de compassion beaucoup
d'empathie mais aussi beaucoup de
détermination
tout ce que nous avons fait dans nos
vies publiques les uns les autres
c'est ce qui nous est arrivé doute mieux
et je conclurai si aurélien me le
permets juste par un mot qui vous
rappelle aussi le regard de cette telle
intensité de jacques chirac
il est vrai que c'était un ami de
famille il est vrai qu'il avait fait
sciences po avec mon père il est vrai
qu'il m'a connu tout petit je sais pas
si l'histoire raconte qu'il m'a fait
sauter sur ses genoux
en tout cas moi je me suis engueulé
demander un autographe et j'avais vu ce
géant arrivée à la maison j'avais neuf
ans sa grande main qui alla du de
l'arrière du front jusqu'au derrière du
crâne il m'avait fait un autographe les
ce type est génial ensuite il m'avait
engueuler parce que j'avais piqué des
chouquettes à matignon était premier
ministre on est en 74 ses souvenirs qui
marque mais ce qui me marquera le plus
évidemment c'est lorsqu'il m'a dit et
j'avais peut-être à peu près votre âge
27 ans j'étais journaliste j'adorais ce
métier c'est un métier que j'ai quittée
en bretou renens puisque c'est un métier
liberté mais même si je sais faire la
différence entre l'information et
l'interprétation où la spéculation fin
voyage permettra de terminer la boucle
[Applaudissements]
là il m'a dit journalisme c'est super tu
as l'air content etc
mais je vais vous dire je vais te dire
maintenant tu vas prendre des
responsabilités tu va m'écouter et quand
chirac vous disait droit dans les yeux
tu vas m'écoutais je n'y avais pas une
question à se poser
on l'écouté il dit le pays a donné il
t'a donné par l'éducation
il t'a donné par la santé il t'a donné
par un mode de vie il t'a donné par la
liberté et maintenant ils te demandent
pas m'écouter je te demande de m'obéir
tu vas lui rendre et tuvalu rendre en
engageant et tuvalu rendre en tant
qu'agent en politique parce que rien de
plus beau que de servir la politique
alors tout ce que je peux vous
transmettre c'est ce regard cette
intensité cette passion que jacques
chirac a donné un jeune à l'époque il ya
presque trente ans et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la l'honneur de pouvoir
échanger partager avec vous bonne chance
à tous merci beaucoup françois percy à
volonter merci à christian jacob notre
président merci à françois baroin
[Applaudissements]